la gestion politique de la crise
sanitaire pour en parler nous sommes
avec denis demonpion éditorialiste
politique bonsoir denis et de mendiants
merci d'être avec nous et emmanuel
macron qui a donc lancé cet état
d'urgence sanitaire était il nécessaire
selon vous à quoi doit-on s'attendre
précisément oui il est absolument
indispensable parce que il suffit basé
sur ce qui s'est passé en chine et
d'ailleurs ce ne sont pas seulement les
politiques en france mais également je
voyais aujourd'hui les professeurs
chinois qui très grande force une loi
qui exerce à shanghai qui disait que si
pas seulement la france mais toute
l'europe ne prend pas des mesures
drastiques de confinement qui sont à mon
sens d'ailleurs encore aujourd'hui très
insuffisante compte tenu des j'allais
dire des infractions qui sont commises
au confinement décrété et bien ses
professeurs chinois qui ont de
l'expérience du virus considère que
l'europe et peut-être même les états
unis c'est de ce qu'ils ont l'air d'en
prendre le chemin est bien géré on le
nombre de cas x 10 tous les 19 jours
s'il n'y a pas de mesures plus
contraignantes que celles qui sont
prises aujourd'hui donc état d'urgence
sanitaire
on peut quand même pas a critiqué une
mesure de bon sens d'ailleurs tous les
médecins soignants professeurs
interrogés aujourd'hui en france sont
d'accord pour que cette mesure soit
prise est respectée avec la plus grande
rigueur
denis demonpion à votre avis on doit
s'attendre à des mesures justement
peut-être encore plus strictes 1 vous
parliez justement de ce médecin
le docteur klein qui effectivement
disait si on n'arrive pas à faire autant
de mesures drastiques en chine
on doit s'attendre au pire on entendait
également un autre journaliste italien
nous dire que ce genre de mesures ne
sont pas vraiment possible en europe
dans des pays latins qui ne sont pas
habitués à beaucoup d'autorité quel est
votre avis oui absolument
c'est toute la question en france c'est
à dire que aussi longtemps qu'il n'y a
pas de mesures coercitives parce que
vous savez il ya toujours en france le
pays des droits de l'homme de la liberté
etc
mais on est dans un cas de figure tout à
fait exceptionnelle enfin tous les
médecins et les professeurs de santé le
dise donc c'est un sujet à traiter avec
effectivement beaucoup de sérieux
je vais en chine s'était passé la chose
suivante il avait commencé au moment du
confinement par autoriser les gens à
faire leurs courses de spa il avait
laissé les magasins ouverts et puis
ensuite très rapidement ils ont pris une
autre mesure c'est que les gens ne
pouvaient évidemment il leur fallait un
papier une autorisation aller faire les
courses que tous les trois jours
et enfin pour finir pour arriver à
juguler ce qu'on en abuse et sa
propagation
ils ont fini par comment dirais-je
organiser des groupes de gens
distribuaient des des paniers au bas des
immeubles et que les gens allaient
chercher il descendait de leur
appartement pour aller les chercher
peut-être faudra-t-il en arriver là en
france parce que vous disiez aussi que
le le comédien le confinement a été a
été annoncé pour 15 jours
mais on voit déjà dans les conversations
est d'ailleurs le premier ministre hier
le disaient que ça ne ferait pas
suffisant donc on voit bien qu'ils sont
en train de préparer l'opinion publique
à accepter une période de confinement
très longue et dans les milieux médicaux
très informés et bien évidemment ils
sont premiers
de la bataille contre les virus et bien
ils disent qu'ils font il faudra au
moins 50 jours de confinement ou banos
effectivement pas très optimiste mais
c'est ce qu'on entend de la bouche des
scientifiques
tous les jours vous avez raison emmanuel
macron qui dit qu'ils pensent tirer qui
s'est engagé pardon à tirer toutes les
conséquences de cette crise comment
interpréter cette promesse on voit déjà
qu'il ya de gros un fléchissement dans
la politique d' emmanuel macron vous
savez je fais pas un fléchissement dans
sa politique c'est que étant donné
l'urgence il n'a eu d'autre choix que de
mettre sous le boisseau tous les projets
de loi qui lave est dans son tiroir et
même de suspendre la réforme des
retraites
non je rappellerai pas la bagarre
qu'elle a 6 i télé la vague de
manifestations
donc en réalité emmanuel macron sadac
sas swiss et il essaie de s'adapter
comme il l'avait fait déjà avec avec les
gilet jaune mais rien ne dit encore
qu'il a pris la mesure des changements
s'imposeront après car sans doute en
faudra-t-il car comment peut-on
expliquer que tous les médicaments
soient fabriqués en dehors de france
n'est ce pas qu'il faille attendre la
chine etc pour pour espérer des
médicaments alors que la france a
toujours été en pointe jusqu'à la
période de délocalisation globalisation
mondialisation alors je sais que ce sont
des des commandes et des avis qui ne
sont pas forcément forcément partagé jeu
je lisais aujourd'hui des déclarations
de pascal lamy l'ancien responsable
européen au sein de l'om c'est qu'ils
avaient beaucoup plus vrai et lui pour
justement cette mondialisation et bien
même encore maintenant devant la
tragédie que nous visons il a encore du
mal à faire une espèce de
l'examen de conscience et et revenir sur
ces idéologies qui ont quand même fait
si on en juge aujourd'hui par ce qui se
passe beaucoup de dégâts merci denis
demonpion éditorialistes politiques
d'avoir été avec nous